this is the jonco underground podcast
number 76 in here with EC
Echo Charles Echo Charlie attention
seeking Behavior this is like good
things to know and understand
I was checking out a website about this
called verywellmind.com
um a lot of people
want and like attention look do you get
some people that are just shy and just
want to blend in yo they exist they're
not a lot of them to be honest with you
but do you remember those kids in high
school I'd always be friends with those
kids in high school like they didn't
want to talk to anybody or whatever
they're kind of real shy but there's
some people they're very few
most people kind of want that attention
um
sometimes it's caused by low self-esteem
sometimes it's caused by loneliness
sometimes caused by jealousy
this website said little kids do it and
that's not it's not unhealthy for little
kids to want some attention right you
don't have to worry about it they're
kind of they're kind of growing and
seeing what the boundaries are in the
world so that's cool there's some actual
disorders
histrionic personality disorder this is
under the cluster of dramatic
personality disorders disorders these
are people that crave attention they're
fixated on their appearance they're
emotional they're dramatic they need
constant validation
there's borderline personal personality
disorder there's another dramatic
personality disorder
and this is the people that think
everyone's out to get them and they're
in unstable relationships and they have
low self-esteem and they have low
self-image and they have intense bursts
of anger and they might even harm
themselves they have impulsive behavior
so these are all things that fall into
this attention seeker and there's also
narcissistic personality disorder and
Oppositional Defiant Disorder and
intermittent explosive disorder so
there's a bunch of legitimate
psychological problems that people can
have
that is an extreme version of seeking
attention
but I'm I don't want maybe we'll cover
that at some point but that's not what I
that's not what why I was thinking about
this
I was thinking about it for just normal
people
and actually wanting to get attention
seeking
under control for normal people and
there was just an interesting list on on
this website
that
I thought it would be smart to cover
because I think it is a good thing to
know and understand to make sure
that you can keep them in mind so that
if we if I am attention seeking I know
what I know what I'm doing and then I
can stop doing it
because here's the thing about this when
you're seeking attention everybody knows
it that's the that's the there's a scary
horrible thing
about being a person is when you're not
aware of what's Happening you're not
aware of what you're doing and most
horrible is when you think other people
can't see what you're doing that to me
is one of the worst disorders just
general disorders you know the person
that thinks they're getting away with
something and they're not they think
you're going to say something they you
you always like to use the example of
name dropping because it's you know
something that people do
and no they think that no one notices
that you just drop the name but
everybody sees it and everybody thinks
the same thing oh you're name dropping
trying to impress me with something
stupid
so it's good that you bring that up
because that's something that anybody
could think you need to do right you
think you need to do it yeah
you don't need to do it and everybody
knows when you're doing it so here's
some of these things that they
put
on this list posting excessively on
social media vying for likes and
comments
interesting yeah right
gotta watch out for that one if you find
yourself like constantly wanting to just
get on there
this seems like it's not gonna be a good
post yeah all right I'll do this
making comments online and in person
that seemed calculated to make people
feel uncomfortable that was a little
weird for me I didn't quite understand
that one maybe it's because making
people feel uncomfortable makes that
people pay attention to you
yeah
this one's obvious bragging about
material wealth physical appearances and
personnel personal successes
and that's one there's nothing worse
you know what I mean
and man how much of social media there's
like a legitimate if you put a pie chart
of social media and one of the slices of
pie was bragging about material wealth
bragging about physical appearance and
bragging about personal success there
would be a there would be at least a
slice of pie yes sir maybe even a big
piece I believe that yes quarter
quarter I wouldn't be surprised but then
again that could be just skewed with the
people I follow because in my experience
I would say yeah quarter cooler scene
right is there any way to post a picture
of you and your freaking car
your new car
that and it's an expensive car yeah a
real nice luxury car is there any way to
post a picture of your luxury car
and not fall into this category that's a
good that's a good doesn't it kind of
seem though like almost like it depends
on the person's personality because like
there is and actually is there a
difference between
sharing your happiness with your
followers like you know like most people
aren't influencers they're just normal
people you know what's a huge line on
this is it really your car
because there's people that have badass
cars and they love cars and they're like
yeah I just got this badass car and I
don't even I don't even consider that to
be bragging or whatever I consider it to
be oh this dude loves cars that's what I
was saying and they're stoked yeah just
like you know when someone graduates um
college or high school or yeah or gets
their online degree whatever like
they're just so happy they're sharing it
with their people you know they're
friends they're not influences you know
and that's the most people they don't
have they're not influencers they're
just normal people so it depends on that
guy's person oh that person's
personality you they get a new car it's
like oh my God you know how you I don't
know you see this where it's like yeah
oh my daughter finally turned 16 he got
her driver's license like are they
bragging because everybody gets their
drivers like it's just happy and they're
never I mean they're just happy you know
what I'm saying so they it could be that
most of the time though kind of like how
you kind of hinted there like you could
smell it on them yeah you could see what
they're doing if you rented a car and
you're photographing it yeah that's
different bro that's kind of that's kind
of that's like another level that's
bragging about personal success or
accomplishment at the same time lying
about it yeah yeah
so watch out for this one
because you might be generally genuinely
stoked about something yeah you might be
kind of bragging yeah and you got to be
careful just make sure man just just pay
attention to it I'm trying to think of
what I've put if I've posted something
that's been what have I posted okay so
then again I don't know I can't read
your mind but this is and this actually
I shouldn't even say it because I don't
want to come off like I'm accusing
people who have done this of doing this
but any you know how like you know you
write books so if it does good on Amazon
you post like oh my gosh thank you and
you say thank you guys for this at all
but or is there a little little sprinkle
of that brag in there you got that past
salary you know like the thing is I
don't know but
as far as actions go that's one of them
that's one of the actions I don't know
your mindset so I don't know if that
that really is that but that's one of
the actions for sure that's a definite
one like hey yep just made the best
seller list again New York Times yeah or
thank you guys for a hundred thousand
subscribers these are kind of humble
brags right yeah same all brag still but
and then again I don't know because
there's there is a very specific
difference between someone sharing their
happiness about something whether they
accomplish it or something it's not
bragging they're sharing their happiness
you know to like their people it depends
man it's hard it's hard that's the thing
with this is I think you will know
and like I like I said you could a lot
of times I don't know but a lot of times
it feels like you could kind of smell it
on a more if someone else does it you
can be like
I see what you're doing cool
congratulations but I do see that you're
bragging or if it if it's genuine
usually there's some pattern of you know
genuineness or whatever so you're like
oh you know like congratulations your
daughter got her license or whatever you
know or you got a sick car good yeah
yeah exactly oh yeah hell yeah that's a
sick car yeah got a guitar
in the hunting world people freak out
about that about like posting pictures
of their kill yup
yeah is is that bragging usually I feel
like that's a little legit bragging [__]
yeah you went out because a lot of times
you don't catch nothing right A lot of
times yeah yeah like I so my younger
brother yata he uh he's a Spearfish yeah
yeah he was really good he probably cut
this 70 pound fish one time I forget
what kind huge he was like
legendary stuff anyway and so anyway I
he he would post stuff that he catches
lobsters like all this stuff and just
you know just like in his little
Community the other guys who do that I I
never saw that as like
bragging about personal success it's
more like
yeah like it's almost like it's a
legitimate brag where you should be
bragging you know like that's the whole
reason you go out you got some success
freaking post that [__] that's what it
feels like so let's just be careful yeah
okay we'll walk away with that let's be
careful about material wealth physical
appearances and personal success
just be careful
it's a warning right it's be cognizant
let's say you do it but you all of a
sudden it becomes habitual
right like you're doing it all the time
and maybe you're doing it reading the
comments right so just be careful of it
next one is acting like everything that
happens is a
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just just all
assistance at Jocko underground.com and
we'll get you taken care of until then
we will see you mobilized
Underground